[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
there's been
a lot of talk about notches lately uh as
it turns out as i'm working on my review
of the galaxy s9 one of those small
changes to the s9
is those bezels
notches
and bezels
are all kind of the same thing so
let's talk about bezels so smartphones
have evolved a lot obviously over the
years you may not think designs have a
whole lot of drastic change i mean
they're still kind of the same shape
generally but one thing has been
consistently true and that is you may
have noticed that screens are now
pushing closer and closer to those edges
now obviously devices
with screens
have bezels around those screens some
bezels are bigger than others and
there's this whole wide spectrum of
different bezels on different devices
and different form factors thick and
thin rounded or sharp we clearly used to
not care about bezels and phones like
have you seen designs from 2005 2008
anytime before this modern movement
seems like there used to be more bezel
than screen but now
we hate them 2018 and recent smartphone
design has been all about how can we get
rid of bezels how can we shrink those
bezels maximize our screen to body ratio
can we get rid of bezels matter of fact
that is the question can we get rid of
bezels and if so how
in theory the answer is just get rid of
everything that's still housed in those
bezels and then you can minimize the
bezels and we have the tech today to
test that theory so side bezels first of
all definitely easy there there's
nothing that has to be in them so pretty
much anyone with a budget has pushed the
screen all the way to the sides of the
rails samsung even has what we call the
infinity display where they literally
curve the glass over the sides so those
are no problem but in the tops and
bottom bezels of phones there are some
things that you'd have to get rid of any
fingerprint sensor on the front got to
get rid of that the earpiece gotta hide
that the front-facing camera
and any proximity sensor or ambient
light sensor and any microphones if we
really want to end bezels and phones if
we really want to shrink the bezel to
zero then we have to find a place to put
all of those things so all right if we
start with the microphones and the light
sensors those are actually pretty small
you can put the microphones on the top
or the bottom of the phone and the light
sensors the proximity sensor does have
to be on the front so you can put it up
to your face and make a call and it
turns the screen off but the ambi light
sensor again is so small it can go
almost anywhere so then there's the
earpiece to make phone calls where do
you put that so we've seen various uses
of this sometimes you kind of double the
earpiece as a front-facing speaker so
you still want it to be pretty big but
when you don't you tend to be able to
shrink it down or shove it way up at the
top of the phone or you can do what we
saw in the xiaomi mi mix which is a
piezoelectric speaker now this is not a
super new technology but we never really
needed it in smartphones before since we
always had room in the bezels but a
piezoelectric speaker actually vibrates
the glass and frame of the phone so that
it sounds just like an earpiece speaker
when you put your ear up to it it's
surprisingly good so that lets you take
the earpiece on the front put it under
the glass shrink the bezel a little more
and then there's a fingerprint sensor uh
this is a fun one since most phones have
shrunk their bezels so much already that
you don't have room for them at the
bottom in that spot anymore so they've
moved to the sides and more commonly the
back now that's fine but a lot of times
you still want to use it when it's flat
on a desk you want to be able to unlock
your phone so you have the option of an
in-glass fingerprint reader so one of my
latest videos goes over a synaptic
sensor that puts an optical fingerprint
reader underneath the display glass for
oled displays so you can shrink the
bezel all the way to zero and still have
a front-facing fingerprint reader for
unlocking your phone definitely worth
checking that whole video out for
roughly where that technology stands and
how close we are to getting it in phones
but so far so good so then the last
thing is
that front-facing camera the selfie
camera can't get rid of it but if you
want to shrink the bezels to zero you
got to put that somewhere else as of
right now we don't have the technology
to put a front-facing camera underneath
the display glass although that would be
really cool
so if you want to hide that you kind of
got to get creative this is the part
where i wish i could hold up the vivo
apex concept phone and show you exactly
how that works but i obviously don't
have one so i'm going to use some
footage from other people who have seen
it so this is what it looks like when
you successfully made every trade-off i
just talked about in getting rid of
everything that's normally housed in
bezels and putting them somewhere else
the light and proximity sensors are
still in the tiny bottom bezel of the
phone and at the top so they still work
the earpiece is the piezoelectric
speaker so it's vibrating the glass and
you can hear it when you put your ear up
to it the fingerprint reader is a
massive optical sensor in the middle of
the display that's underneath about a
third of the glass
and the front-facing camera is actually
on a motor that pops up in this little
housing from the top of the phone when
you turn it on that is the length they
went to to give us this bezel-less phone
or this concept every single one of
these things was removed from the bezel
they used a flexible oled display and
curved all the drivers and edges
underneath and that leaves you with this
this beautiful six inch bezel-less
screen but here's the thing
it's a concept phone and not to burst
anyone's bubble but it's a constant
phone for a reason this thing probably
cost them a couple thousand dollars to
make and was also extremely difficult
for them to make and having motorized
moving parts like that in a smartphone
is generally not good for durability and
also waterproofing so there's a lot of
little things you don't really think
about when it's a concept phone and it
looks so great but it just looks so
great so that brings us to the question
of what can today's phone makers do in a
reasonable budget with today's
technology to get closer to bezel-less
well today you can move the light
sensors around you can move the
fingerprint sensor to the back or even
get rid of the fingerprint sensor
entirely you can shrink the earpiece or
even get rid of it if you're feeling
daring but pretty much everyone at this
point realizes the front-facing camera
is like that last step it's very
important to a lot of people so we
aren't quite as ready to take as many
risks with it so that's how we got
this this whole notch situation where we
really want to push the boundaries and
go closer to bezel list and we shrink
the top bezel on the side and the bottom
but we didn't really know where else to
put the front-facing camera
so we just gave you this in fact if you
look back the essential phone got it all
kicked off they had the camera and the
front-facing ambient light sensor and
proximity sensor and then that little
slit at the top is the earpiece and then
of course we got all those front-facing
sensors in iphone 10 and sure enough now
there's rumors of lg g7 neo doing the
same thing asus zenfone 5z the rumored
oneplus 6 and probably many more to come
but if you're wondering how i feel about
the notch uh this notch isn't the future
it isn't even a feature
it's just it represents this awkward
middle stage between
cell phone designs of the past and the
bezel-less that we want when we figure
out what to do with that front-facing
camera these notches are just kind of
the best ideas designers are trying to
come up with now for finding clever ways
to keep a front-facing camera but also
shrink as much of the bezels as possible
at this point you can only really go
like the samsung way or the apple way
they've kind of coined their camps the
samsung way is we don't want a notch
we're just gonna shrink and keep the
bezels and just pack them as tight as
possible on the top and bottom of the
phone but keep all the sensors where
they normally go
better looking for sure at this point
but it's more more stable that way uh
the iphone way the apple way is more of
it's aggressive it's uglier but it's
more pushing towards that bezel-less
future that we want when we finally
figure out what to do with those
front-facing sensors
it's just a shame people have to copy it
it's kind of like when apple just
decided they wanted wireless audio to be
the future and stopped putting a
headphone jack in the phone it's weird
and it's awkward at first but it
definitely moves us forward to that more
seamless future so it starts as a big
ugly notch now with our current
technology but ideally next year shrinks
a lot shrinks again and eventually when
we get the technology to hide that
camera and get rid of those sensors on
the front completely
it's gone as far as today's phones go i
gave the essential phone my design and
build award because it did the notch as
best as we seem to be able to with
today's technology like i said it shoved
that earpiece way up at the top and it
has both the proximity sensor and the
ambient light sensor and the
front-facing camera all up in that tiny
little notch in the center so i think
the next essential phone hopefully there
is one can keep basically the same
design just like shrink the chin even
more and try to keep that top notch as
tiny as possible bigger screen maybe
tiny side bezels i'd be pretty pumped
about that so okay basically to
summarize everything
on our march towards that coveted 100
screen to body ratio towards these
bezel-less phones we came up against
this obstacle of the technology we have
right now that is we can't hide all
those sensors and that's what created
this notch
and if we're going to move past it if
we're going to get past it as just like
this little phase in the history of
smartphones we have to be optimistic
about the technology that we saw on
phones like that apex phone so i'm
crossing my fingers for that i'm hoping
it's sooner than later obviously i'm
just pumped that there are people that
are creative enough to push the
boundaries in ways differently than just
following the way that apple and
essential were pushing the boundary to
begin with hopefully it's just a phase
until then bravo vivo we'll see that
hopefully soon
thanks for watching talk to you in the
next one
peace